there's all these other spaces that we
haven't used so I'm going to take
advantage of that and that's something
some of the rest of this okay now some
of these are a bit trickier so I'm going
to walk you through this next one and
you want to watch quite closely okay so
this next bit this next week I'm gonna
write the instruction for you because
it's not in your textbook I'd like you
to write it down next to where you drawn
this diagram so you've done the
translation this time let's do a
rotation
he's the rotation I want us to do okay
rotate you should write this down we
rotate the shape it's called a b c d e f
g we're gonna rotate it and whatever
we're going to rotate it about a
particular point because if I say rotate
you don't mean you don't know if I mean
like rotate around here all like rotate
around here I look at the other hands of
the clock right look at the hands of the
clock I think we all agree that the
heads are rotating right but they Hansen
on rotating like this see this like this
pan is rotating but that's not how those
hands are taking what are they rotating
about what's the center it's the middle
of the clock yeah very good so I'm going
to take as my inspiration we're gonna
rotate this shape about the origin okay
we have a better name for it then okay
so this one's a bit trickier this one's
a bit trickier so wants you to watch
quite closely what color would you like
me to do I just use blue pink
Pete pink was in first so let's go
people okay oh I'm missing something I
need to rotate this I need a sign I need
followed your dinner table we might do
um okay well I mean I want to use this
space over here so I'm gonna go
clockwise okay so now now I do what
should have put your pens down again put
your pens and pencils down again for a
minute and watch this next bit cuz it's
a bit sneaky in order to do this
rotation well it'll help a little bit if
I know if you've ever seen a building
that's being actually constructed right
if they're building like this tall I
don't know how many of you sort of go
past our castle towers and that kind of
thing if you're building like a tall
skyscraper like a twenty one storey
block next to a new train station around
there around that what you do is you put
all of this extra stuff right
we call it scaffolding okay so that you
can reach the higher parts of the
building it helps you okay
so what we're gonna do is get this guy
out of the way we're gonna do some
scaffolding I'm gonna use chair wasn't
you did you pick pink okay we're gonna
use jaren's chosen color for the
scaffolding and then I'm gonna draw the
image in a whole new color okay so watch
as I do these steps this time I want you
to do them with me okay so pick up your
roll up big oh you're alone
first thing we're gonna do let's start
with a okay first thing we're gonna do
is draw from a to the point where
rotating around that's the origin right
so it looks something like this how's
that look
does that go straight there what do you
think yes look okay all right now I'm
going to take that whole line and I'm
gonna use that just like the hands of
the clock okay so imagine this is my
this is like my minute hand if you like
okay it's gonna rotate 90 degrees around
you may like to use your ruler to
measure how long this length is okay and
then once you've got that we're going to
rotate it 90 degrees like that okay so I
think if I'm reading mine right let's
have a look here it's gonna be six I
think it's gonna end up over there what
do you think does it look like it's gone
90 degrees and clockwise yeah so you can
see it's come all the way around here
now before I move on to the next point I
want to notice something really cool and
interesting this is the number plane
right so I've got all these coordinates
everywhere what are the coordinates of a
can someone tell me the coordinates of a
yeah Aidan the original a negative two
comma six perfect okay now have a look
at the coordinates of my new shape or my
new point rather this is my new a - what
are its coordinates look carefully
look carefully [ __ ] what do you think
Oh hold on he's five over here
I think it's moves over there right six
I think it's a six think it's a six and
I think I had the two right now look do
you see these numbers are related that's
not a coincidence
is it right those numbers are connected
to each other so it's really important
we'll use that later all right what else
can we do we're doing a now we're gonna
do B right I should have put this one in
green so let's put this guy over here
this is the start of our new shape right
you can see that B is actually gonna be
no yeah see what I did there
looks like B's gonna be here or the new
B rather be - can you see it
do you see how it's rotated around 90
degrees and clockwise right so I've got
my new a - I've got my new B - I'll make
them all the right color and you can see
if I do this for a and B and C and keep
rotating around I'm gonna get my new
shape why don't you try and do the rest
of the shape and then just like this
blue one we can compare and see what
they look like so you can write yeah
yeah good okay
so I'm gonna complete my rotated shape
it's gonna look like this you might
notice whoopsie-daisy
you might notice it has to overlap with
your first shape did you notice that
when you started rotating things around
so I think you're gonna get these guys
in here
and then where do I go from here where
does the arrow face the arrows pointed
down let's try this I'm finishing off
this rotated shape okay so you can see
I'm going to go up like this and there
is my new image okay so if you are on
the way this is what you ought to end up
with okay now the last thing I'm gonna
show you which is really cool and then
I'll just write some questions there you
can do from homework and then you can
pack up is that I asked some people are
you know we've done sliding we've done
translating we've done rotating the last
one left is reflection right there's no
reflection so you actually don't lead in
reflection okay well what I'm gonna do
is I asked um unless these guys up here
to help me with them to help me with a
reflection Shh
and what they did was they took this
image the green arrow you know and they
see what I did that approach they
reflected that shape across the x-axis
correct me if I'm wrong but I think this
is the shape you got right down here
yeah excellent okay so I'm just gonna
finish it off now what I want to ask you
is this to get this purple shape down
here that's a bit wonky for you can do
to you so get to this purple shape down
here
how many transformations did I do
I think I did too right I went from the
original to the green one what did I do
that was rotation right and then I went
from green to purple and so our
effectives that was - right now - so now
my question is let's get rid of all of
this extra stuff here is there a way I
can get from here to here not in true
steps but in one give him a second let
him look I will ask you for the question
to the outside a second look can you see
it can you see away I couldn't do it
okay these guys are bursty what do you
guys tell us what you guys found okay so
if I do a different rotation look at
this this is so cool
here's two - right do you see how they
got from here and then rotated around
what direction clockwise I think I've
gone this way right and so it's kind of
come around like that I really like that
is there another way through this annul
about see Oh which way clockwise are you
sure
yeah which way will it face I'm going to
put one last line into here because I
really love this answer and I have a
different one which is what's so cool
about bats have a look at this line can
you look carefully at this line for me
yeah look if you can y'all turn your
heads can you turn your heads right like
that 45 degrees and if you think of this
is like the middle can you see that this
is
our a reflection these guys are so cool
they love to but today yeah